the future video games is coming in 2016
like my hardy Eric tay and it is in the
form of a pair of glasses that you strap
to your face these glasses I'm going to
be cheap they're going to cost you six
hundred dollars but what part what price
could you put on an experience like
being able to digitally gel in the
comfort of your own Oh to put those
glasses on and live in a virtual world
what's the price six hundred dollars six
hundred dollars too much for an oculus
rift we got the the I guess the consumer
version is finally X we've had the dk1
SDK days and stuff dropping internet and
they've been kind of open for pre-order
publicly kind of developers but like we
got them but this is the one that's kind
of like all right this is for the public
600 bucks a lot more if you're
encountered a lot more if you're in
Europe it's actually a bit closer to
seven hundred bucks if you put tax and
shipping at least for us in California
too much for you Eric I can watch I
don't know it's weird like the last time
I paid six hundred dollars for a piece
of hardware with the ps3 and man did I
regret that do you buy a PC recent
recently no I haven't but that is more
than 600 yes fine there which you're
gonna need some type of probably good
graphics card to go with your list no
free USB 3.0 ports I think as well as
our own yeah yeah that's that's easy
with my macbook airs out oh yeah the six
hundreds a bit much for me it's the most
expensive like I think like peripheral
or like a Don type of heart that's the
thing though like is it a peripheral
like is this thing a peripheral because
it's not like a that's not like a
connector a playstation move like this
is it's a platform all on its own like
right yeah i think by technical
definition it is labeled a peripheral
but it very much is this i as a person
who's been positive on VR for a long
time like a believer ever since i played
you know that one game that seems you
know everybody has that one game that
turns out but it does it seems it's i
think it could be a contender in like
the living room lineup eventually maybe
like end of 2017 i think i said or
something but right now it is like
tasted i think it's a little too
expensive for me I get why they're doing
it like I think you could talk a little
more about them you know why they need
to do this because they don't have a
huge
software lineup yet that could ya bring
back their investment but I I won't be
paying six hundred dollars for right
away I would be waiting for a price like
a drop later on especially cuz ya that
like back in two thousand six that was a
that was the cost of an entire platform
from Sony yeah but that was two thousand
six about money is now like that's just
that bad boy for inflation and they
talking about like over a thousand or so
so they're not making any money off of
it farmer lucky was on Twitter today
sort of she's shouting that out and he's
very excited about it the price i feel
like the price it's like too much for me
like I was willing was my birthday
yesterday so I was thinking you know
what from me to me I might like get one
of these if it's man 400 mark probably
500 out to think about it and when it
said 600 I was gonna enhance that's a
little bit too much but I kind of prefer
that to the alternative which is that
they release this piece of kit for like
350 400 bucks and it's like this nerfed
piece of technology because like you
know if you look at this and it's kind
of different for us in the world because
you bring up the PlayStation right which
is exactly the first Delta someone's
going to think of and like the video
games world and people watch it is going
to be fans of video games and play video
games they think on those terms but if
you think about stuff like iPads or like
iPods even iPhones especially and like
consumer technology that gets really
expensive like it starts expensive and
our perception of how much it should
cost is around here and then after a
while they kind of find this like
equilibrium where people are willing to
spend more because they hear it's a good
experience and there's more software
first you know after a year or two the
field and then like the cost gets a
little bit lower because they figured
out the production chains and stuff and
then eventually what kind of get there
so like to me this feels like ipad
version one or like I've watch or Apple
watcher like [ __ ] like that right where
it's like I care though like I feel like
I was having this conversation in there
earlier because he was like what could I
do with six hundred dollars just so I
can do these like newsy type jokes right
and I was like well yeah what about a
phone and this and that and then I
started thinking well on the flip side
of that yeah these are the same costs
iPad you know iphone they're the same
cost but you use your phone all the time
like well I wouldn't say all the time
but you use it a good amount of time in
the day every day right yeah and
anywhere anywhere and the oculus yeah
I kind of understand why it's so
expensive but you know you have all
these other hardware options that you
can do that you can buy that are you
know that you said of course equating
cost and like I would use that all the
time like I can use my I've had to surf
the web I knew this i could do that you
know like my oculus like I guess it's
for this one or two or the key Valkyrie
because that was a good demo but like
you know like okay well it's like I
guess when you when those first like the
Apple watch is like a good sort of
example of it doesn't really do all that
much but certain people find like really
good use cases for that like people who
can't have their phones in work or
people who you know want to do a lot
more fitness like use their iphones for
training more than they did twitter you
know what kind of works out there like
specific use cases so i feel like maybe
the oculus like it's it's a whole it's
literally literally talking about a new
frontier in entertainment like it sits
on treaded ground so like it should cost
a [ __ ] ton of money it should it should
be this like weird like think about what
it was four years ago when you had to
like it looked like [ __ ] it didn't
really work the tech cost a fortune like
we were talking about setting up rooms
but like those are the roller like pad
areas like we're kind of it's already
because the fact that it i feel like the
fact that it's Underground is already
kind of amazing somebody on Twitter
earlier today was telling me they were
using like cab you know computer-aided
yeah drawing or whatever like CAD
software in VR and they had like this
unit which reserved fifty thousand
dollars because that's what like
industry stuff costs and it's like not
as good as oculus like so i think that
like we have someone at six hundred
bucks that's like as good as the oculus
rift is because they are just [ __ ]
really good yeah it's kind of cool it's
like I think it's amazing I think it's
amazing we have that it's just when we
think about it in videogame terms it's
difficult especially we look at the
software cuz like you said like 'hey--
Valkyrie like name another big games
coming in akko's it's hard right yeah
there's some games is like loads of
stuff to have it like does that rhombus
and rune thing of ruining this like an
arts thank dreams is gonna know that'll
be so needy are but they take in terms
of that's the thing because we're we've
got a lot of so many of you are still
fresh in our heads dodge the London high
stuff Ace Combat seven of course
100-foot robot call yeah res infinite so
all that stuff is Sony of you but then
like you know job simulator but we
played me on deflate and at the
PlayStation experience as well and
it's also gonna come out on oculus like
a lot of these are coming in monkeys
actually I think on just 40 buck off its
gonna knock is the climb yeah I don't
even think that's a Morpheus only game
matter i think remember the climb yeah
is this thing i did like a rock climbing
game recently or i went to an event they
didn't tell me was gonna be a rock
climbing game and I'm petrified of
heights and and they didn't tell me and
I put on the goggles the glasses and
it's VR so it's gonna like trigger that
yeah shaky like sweating I was drenched
by the end of it it's terrifying it's an
amazing it did scare you that was
thought that was the thing it was it
felt like such a real sensation I had
the same symptoms i do if i was standing
on the edge of a building you know know
that i do that often but it's still like
it triggered it like it's going to go
rock climbing i specifically did it to
get over a fear of heights oh really
clearly i haven't yet but it's still
that's that's why I'm like such an
optimist about VR but like you said it's
it's so hard to compare it to anything
else that has happened video games in a
while because you know like we keep
talking about consoles but ps4 we the
price was a big deal but it's still like
we know we're eventually gonna get it's
an established thing it sound like let's
be honest a station for is three hundred
and fifty dollars now yeah it is [ __ ]
no we're good near as good as pcs are
already right like those consoles were
cheap when they came out for a reason
yeah like the Xbox one is done like in
terms of like its power it's done ps4
right behind it like it last year was
like a damning indictment of the pair of
those consoles in comparison to PC
because we already it's tough looking so
much better like within within 24 months
yeah so like I don't know technology
Kozma that's good one just worried
because like again I do understand the
cause but that price point puts it at a
point where even you who was interested
in buying it right aren't going to buy
it so you're looking at enthusiasts
people that have the money to spend or
if you're lucky enough to kick-start and
fund it in the beginning you're actually
getting it for half off oh cool i think
if you kick started it because a Palmer
came out yesterday I think and said you
know if you kick started and got the dk1
you're getting it for free Wow so I
think it was only 300 to get into it so
now you're getting a half off so kudos
to those people that got in a brown on
that I have no idea he's at CES the
moment mans ever be our guy yeah brushed
polymers honed by anyways yeah I like at
this price point it's like I'm afraid
like I'm slightly afraid like I know
they got a lot of money behind it
you know so it's going to be fine for a
couple years but at what point is there
enough people wanting to you know buy it
when the applications come out when the
price shop comes out you know like does
that attempt us to buy it then that's
kind of like this slight barrier of
entry and that's kind of the fear
because if people can't get it into
their hands and experience it which is
like something Peter keeps harkening
right like he killed me I mean while you
were saying earlier yeah the minute you
try the one I did the oculus touch thing
with the control that was like single
most crazy demo I've ever done in my
entire life that was that was like some
[ __ ] brilliant Blade Runner [ __ ] or
like a lot more mad [ __ ] I was insane I
was like I was talking people last night
about it like this is like months later
so yeah it's like it's that type of
thing it's like so it's just it's just a
shame that you're right it that it's
that much because I was like willing to
go in the limb and like spend outside my
budget just to get one mr. secure cuz
then I'd be like an April I be like a
hair I was saving money up until April
yeah but even that was too much for me
it's got such a weird like kind of
double sided challenge to confront you
know you have to get into the public's
hands going to cost enough that it's not
gonna be a complete loss so could you
say the same thing about iPads and
iPhones oh yeah like I'd obviously like
if you're comparing the abilities of the
two things it's not gonna be a good
comparison to Jack selling to the video
that's I not like completely business
minded but I see why there it's a little
pricier than what we might think I was
thinking it might be some around 500 and
then I saw other people saying 700 which
it kind of is 700 with taxes like you
said at least here but it's just such a
they have to you know get it in the
public awareness is there I think
especially like because you know the
part of our job is to try to tell people
it's mmm the people mean like I don't
know like the optimist of VR like it's
it's worth trying but you know they
still have to mount that hurdle of
actually getting it out there and it's
such a weird how what do we price it in
order to do that but also like you know
not to just tanked ray and they're not
running money off it so you gotta say if
they're doing any less they'd be taking
a loss and you know people are gonna say
all you should like you should take a
loss on it so that it gets some people
because this is like for VR but i don't
know i think 2016 we're always talking
about 2016 is like the year that of VR
like 26 a probably going to be the year
of like VR early adoption like 2017
hopefully will be the year
yeah when everyone starts getting into
it but like it's kind of interesting
it's good it's good that we are what are
we today is the sixth of January and
we've already had a price on oculus so
the wheels are turning so we're gonna be
are happening and it's tapping pretty
soon as long as you can afford it Eric
tell you Mike mihari thanks so much for
coming on talk about virtual reality let
us know what you think about V or in the
comments below is 600 bones or 700 if
you're paying taxes in many states don't
play taxes on technology portland
portland is the oregon oregon or there's
like a lot a lot a shot going on it
right now or they don't want to do they
could probably use some Viera now
they're bored up there I know you can
around that hang in Federal Reserve yeah
or whatever a federal land that's not
good we need food moment sections are
descending into madness already almost
got it let us know you think I'll Pamela
chalk this shirt cost of whether or not
you're happy it costs so much or whether
you wish it was cheaper or are you just
happy to play it may be in version 2
comes out next year let us know in the
comments below